it's sort of the elephant in the room
which is politics and politics today and
what's happening in America right now
and you guys have this very popular very
funny political show and you must be
hearing from people all the time for
example Matt you play a press secretary
you have people coming to you it's
actually was posted online at one point
I believe when Sean Spicer was having
some problems people thought oh my god
Sean Spicer is worse Mike McLintock
literally one minute his first press
conference one minute into it I got 500
tweets saying this guy's worse than Mike
McClintock yeah for real and it hasn't
stopped people compared Mike and it's
accurate but mike is better at the
podium than Sean Spicer much better at
the podium right I will say that yeah
maybe not but maybe he might be better
at running like his personal life yes
who knows yes
you